ask myself a question what happened to
us
when size will open in 1966 it's with
the eighth reactor that this country had
built in just seven years why have we
never got back to that kind of Rhythm
had we lost the gumption
and dynamism of our parents and
grandparents it gets worse when size
will be fantastic white Dome was
completed in 1995 it was the fifth
reactor in seven years now remember 1995
an era that was technologically so
primitive that people used to use things
called car phones and went down to
Blockbusters to rent VHS videos think of
the Colossal technical progress in other
areas and contrast the paralysis in
British nuclear energy how many new
nuclear power stations new nuclear power
stations have we built in the 27 years
since how many have been connected to
the grid how many slices of bread can we
toast with the additional nuclear power
we've created how many washing machine
can we power
how many families have been helped with
extra nuclear energy
the answer is none zero zilch
the French have loads of new
capacitations
already who built four more since 1995
bringing their total reactor Fleet up to
about 56. the Indians have added about
12 the Chinese have built more than 50
additional nuclear reactors since 1995.
and you know why we failed it's not even
as though we have some cultural aversion
to to nuclear power and I just met those
those nice protesters outside they were
it wasn't kind of atom craft nine danker
uh that there wasn't some Lefty thing uh
that they seem to be objecting to the
disruption to the pure nimbyism out
there uh it's it's that's not that's not
the issue I will diagnose the the
problem
it's called myopia
it's called short termism
it's a chronic case of politicians not
being able to see beyond the political
cycle for 13 years the previous labor
government did absolutely nothing to
develop this country's nuclear industry
they said it didn't make economic sense
I haven't even said that in their in
their manifestable thanks a bunch Tony
and thanks a bunch Gordon tell that to
British businesses earned industries
that are now desperately short of
affordable and reliable electricity tell
that to families that are struggling
with the cost of heat and light this
winter and they're not only the they're
not the only culprits because in the
run-up to the 2010 election as you
you'll have seen famous video on YouTube
now Nick Clegg the then leader of the
liberal Democrats now some kind of tech
lobbyist in California said that the UK
shouldn't build more nuclear power
stations like sizewell C and he didn't
say it was unsafe he didn't have what he
called a theological objection he said
that the problem was
that it wouldn't even be completed no
point starting it he said because it
wouldn't even be completed until guess
when 2021 or 2022 so gee thanks Nick
and it's because of that kind of myopia
that here in the country that first
split the atom we have only 15 of our
energy uh from nuclear and our
electricity from nuclear and it is
falling whereas in France it is at 70
percent and we ask ourselves why France
is more self-reliant than ourselves when
it comes to energy and why they found it
relatively easier to hold down costs yes
nuclear always looks when you begin it
always looks relatively expensive to
build and to run
but
it is certainly cheap by comparison with
hydrocarbons today
in fact
if Hinckley
Point C were already running this year
hit me Point C we're already running
this year been delayed for ages and ages
of course it'll be cutting fuel bills by
three billion pounds
I'll say it again pinkly Point C we're
running now you'll be cutting our
National Fuel bills by three billion
pounds so you have to look ahead and you
have to be aware of the false economy if
you have an old kettle
ages to boil it may cost you 20 pounds
to replace it
but if you get a new one you'll save 10
pounds a year for every year on your 10
10 pounds a year every year on your
electricity bill and I remember when the
government finally did the deal on
Hinckley uh Hinckley C in fact I think I
was already sitting in the cabinet and I
remember some people protesting then
about the about the strike price that we
did 92 pounds 50 uh per megawatt hour
per kilowatt hour it was very very
expensive but it doesn't it doesn't look
very expensive today
that's why we need to pull our national
finger out and get on with sizewell C
that's why we're putting 700 million
pounds into the deal just part of the
1.7 billion pounds of government funding
available for developing a large-scale
nuclear project to final investment
stage FID in this Parliament and
in the course of the next few weeks I am
absolutely confident that it will get
over the line and we will get it over
the line because it will be absolute
Madness not to